You are listening to
radio lab radio from W.
N y. S. E. N. N. P. R.
[inaudible].
Okay. So Robert,
you know that like talking about music
in a way that's compelling can be kind of
hard, very hard, particularly the
music you like. Yeah, exactly.
It's really hard to sit to, to build a
bridge. And so when people do it well,
I just feel like you got
to give them prompts.
And I just ran into a really great
podcast that I think everyone should be
listening to. It's called meet the
composer. Uh, it's from Q2 music, uh,
which is sort of the digital
sister station of WQXR.
And it's kind of what it sounds, you know,
every episode they introduce
you to one composer,
but they do such a good job of seducing
you into listening and maybe caring
about music you wouldn't normally
listen to care about that.
I just thought, you know,
I really want to play some of their
latest episode for you because they just
focused on one of my favorite composers,
a guy by the name of John Luther Adams.
Oh, the opera guy, John. No, no, no,
no, no, no. This is John Luther Adams,
different John Adams and the other guy
I've heard of John Quincy Adams when he
was a former president United States. Yes.
This John Adams is a composer who makes
music that sort of conjures these wide
open spaces that kind of invite you in
but also seems sort of indifferent to you
and maybe might kill you. It
has that kind of feeling to it.
I am intrigued. Okay. So,
so how does it be like we're going to
speak to this guy, this and this? The, uh,
the documentary begins, um, and by
the way, it's hosted by Nadia Sirota.
It begins, uh, with John Luther Adams
as a boy playing in a rock band.
Imagine 14 year old John in a cover
band in New Jersey opening for acts like
Buffalo Springfield and
playing predominantly the
three bs or the three base,
the Beatles,
the beach boys.
Okay.
So we started out as a cover band and
I got bored with that and so did my
buddies. And, uh,
over time we started trying our hand at
songwriting and I was a big fan of Frank
Zappa,
Frank Zappa,
the tee totalling 1960s and seventies
musician and polymath with wildly
eccentric tastes expanding from
rock to jazz to European modernism.
[inaudible] off as good as no should,
contemporary classical pieces.
And on the back of Frank's early LPS,
there would always be this
intriguing little quote,
the present day composer refuses to die
at Garver Rez and my little rock and
roll buddies. And I would read that and
scratch our heads and wonder how, Oh,
who is this for? Easy Guy, right? And
one day my friends take Einhorn was how
much Jane through the record bins and a
shopping in the West village and came
across this album with this mad scientist
on the cover with the great shock
of electrostatic green hair,
bushy eyebrows, stern countenance.
And the title was the music
of that guy for his volume.
So he bought it home and we
were Alpha groups.
It just all sounds like
a bunch of noise to me.
Her, this desert, this ocean.
This is forbidding mountains of, of sound.
And I remember thinking, I'll never
be able to know where I am in this.
I don't know what to hang on to.
So your response to what is this
music was just to immerse yourself.
Give me more. Yeah. Which has always
been my response to any new experience.
And I often encourage young musicians,
especially young composers, you know,
listen to everything you
can get your ears on,
especially the stuff you
think you don't like.
I started to realize, oh, okay,
there's that repeated note on the
oboe and okay, that's a landmark.
They can grab onto that. Oh, and here's
this place where there's sort of a,
a tattoo figure, what the snare drums,
and then these unisons stabs
in the rest of the percussion.
Gradually we began to learn how to
listen to the forbidding deserts of rent.
[inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible].
Did that affect the music you
guys were making? Oh, sure.
It meant that the process that was
already underway was just accelerated.
We rapidly abandons the,
the one four five chords and the backbeat
and the four bar phrases and started
discovering cage and Feldman in nine.
Carol and Pauline Oliveros Wilson
were coffers and on and on,
so thank you Frank Salpa.
I love that. That was his
response to music that you know,
can be defined as very alienating. I
mean for Rez is not easy stuff, you know,
but instead of just writing it off
as ugly, he was like ugly. How? Yeah,
exactly. In case, just to
skip forward a little bit,
in the meeting composer hour from Q2,
John Luther Adams goes off to school.
He has a teacher named a,
I believe it's James Tenney is
one of his first big influences,
but he goes off to school at Cal Arts
and right afterwards he meets one of his
next big end [inaudible].
Well, I had just left cal arts,
hadn't yet gone to Alaska and I would
take long walks in the early morning and
again at dusk and I became
captivated by this singer.
Then I kept hearing deep in the woods
and I could never find the bird,
but I couldn't get enough of the song.
I started taking notes.
The birds became my
teacher after James Tenney
[inaudible]
and the result was a series of pieces
that I composed between 1974 and 79 called
simply songbird songs.
Woo
[inaudible].
What was the translation process between
hearing this bird song that you just
couldn't get enough of and constructing
a narrative in working with the bird
songs? I just tried to take dictation.
I try to listen carefully to the birds
where they are as they're singing and
write down what I hear.
I'm not interested in
accuracy because if I were,
I just make recording
and play the recording
[inaudible]
I'm interested in what gets lost
in translation because after all,
this is music. This is perhaps a
language that we will never understand.
[inaudible]
also, there weren't very many field
recordings available in those days,
but there were some and I decided,
no, I'm not going to use though.
I really wanted to hear them
and to learn them for myself.
Now it's actually very different
from the way I work much of the time.
Rather than working with very specific
details of the music and then building a
piece up,
I usually sculpt away the whole field of
sound and I'll work with one big shape
or image or color or atmosphere then
that I have in mind that I can't quite
hear, but I want to hear and
try to hear that sense that,
write that down as clearly as I can.
And then all the moment to
moment details of the music.
We're listening to excerpts
from an hour from QT music,
from their fantastic series, meet
the composer. This one is on the, uh,
composer, one of my favorites,
John Luther Adams. No,
after the a songbird
piece, John is living in la
and he gets kind of fed
up. I hated [inaudible]
Los Angeles the whole
time that I was there.
I felt lost and not in a good way.
It was such an interesting contrast
because it was one of the most explosive
periods of my life in terms of, of
discovery. But at the same time, uh,
there was this kind of inner knowing like
just felt lost in the freeways and all
that sprawl city that seemed
to just go on forever.
It made me long for home,
which I never felt that I had because
we moved all the time and I had grown up
here and there in equally
homogenous suburban surroundings.
So there was this deep in articulate
hunger to find a place to which I might
belong.
[inaudible]
the place where Adam's belonged,
it turns out was off the
grid in wild open spaces.
[inaudible]
I went north in the summer of
1975 so I was 22 that summer.
And from the moment I arrived,
I knew I'd found home.
When you showed up in
Alaska, what did you see?
What did you hear that made you
feel like you knew you were home?
We're here to begin.
It all really starts in the summer of
1975 when I first canoed across admiralty
island, went into Glacier Bay,
hiked on the Tundra of Donnelley.
I eventually made my way to the
Brooks range to the Arctic. You know,
there was and still is in those places
a sense of openness and space and
possibility as well as danger.
These are big places
in which we feel very,
very small and we realized that we're
insignificant and the place doesn't care
if we are there or not. And uh,
the weather or the bear or the river can
rise up at any moment and snuff me out.
And you know, I find
a certain reassurance,
a certain profound comfort in that
I was trying to reconnect with the larger,
older world that we still want to have it,
but that we, that we forget
[inaudible]
then Alaska allowed me to feel like
I was the only person in that place.
[inaudible]
so in the summer of 1977,
I visited the Arctic National Wildlife
Refuge and we flew over the crest of the
parks range and Allan to the coastal
plain, the Arctic coastal plain in there.
And the distance was the ice
Iceland. And of course the sun,
even even in mid summer, the sun
doesn't get very high on the horizon.
So there's this incredible deep, warm,
saturated light like the colors.
And the shadows and
everything just stands out.
And then you get out on the Tundra
and you lose all sense of scale.
I remember one evening was a buddy.
We are just so excited to be alive
and out in that Arctic evening.
Alight.
And we saw this white rock out across
the Tundra and this odd looking thing.
And I said, well, why don't we walk over
there? Why don't we hike to that rock?
We hiked and we high.
And of course the Tundra is not easy
to walk on, but we kept walking,
we kept walking, you know, the
rock didn't get any closer.
So we kept walking
and then suddenly we stopped
because the rock flew away.
Huh? The Rock was a snowy
owl sitting on the Tundra
and you know,
it could have been a 12 foot
outcropping of white stone. You just,
you lose yourself in that
place, in that light,
into that endless space. And
that's what I want in music.
That's so beautiful.
We're hearing bits from Q2
music's meet the composer series.
This one on John Luther
Adams. Continue in a moment.
[inaudible]
this is Darlene calling
from Kampala. Uganda.
Radiolab is supported in part by the
National Science Foundation and by the
Alfred p Sloan Foundation,
enhancing public understanding of science
and technology in the modern world.
More information
aboutSloan@wwwdotsloan.org
hi, I'm Robert Krulwich. Radiolab
is supported by Morgan Stanley.
Your son has a gift for gymnastics.
Your daughter has her eye on a little
startup in the valley and you want to
retire early.
How do you create a wealth plan that
reflects all the complexity of a modern
family?
Start with a financial advisor who
understands individuals and knows how to
bring families together around
both shared and personal goals.
More information@morganstanley.com
slash conversations Morgan Stanley Smith
Barney, LLC, members civic.
Hi,
this is Chris from New Jersey.
Radiolab is supported by Reuters TV,
a new tool for busy people who want to
know what on earth is going on made by
the world's largest news organization
with over 2,500 reporters all over the
planet. Water's TV is video news
as it should be. No hot air,
no talking heads and no theatricals
available on your favorite device. Ios,
android, Roku, or apple
TV. It's personalized,
always up to date and ready when you are.
See for yourself, go to Reuters. Dot.
TV slash radio lab.
This is Mike in San Luis Obispo.
Radiolab is supported by
intercontinental hotels and resorts,
presenting their podcast series
stories of the intercontinental life.
Take a multisensory journey
into the intercontinental life.
And here are three stories
about worldliness that will
excite your imagination.
Relax in the club center,
Continental Lounge with Peter Hessler
to learn about the transformation of
Beijing.
Take a sidecar through Beijing to discover
the more discreet side of travel and
explore the famous seven nine, eight
or district with intercontinental.
Worldliness is becoming a
part of any place you visit.
Download the stories of the
intercontinental life on iTunes.
We're back. I'm Jad Abumrad. I remember
Krulwich. This is radio lab and uh,
we're taking a, uh, we're taking this
podcast to present some music, right?
I'm, uh, I'm foisting it on you,
Robert, and on our listeners,
but we notice that I'm not, I'm not,
you're not running away scared. I'm,
that's good. I take that
as a sign of success and a,
the excerpts that you've been hearing
come from Q2 a wonderful series meet the
composer particular hour that they've
just produced on the composer John Luther
Adams, who after he moved to Alaska
began to make these amazingly huge,
sometimes serene,
sometimes violent pieces.
And you know what I think
about when I hear his work,
I remember when I first encountered looney
tunes and the way that the like them
them has this sort of an
inherent meaning to it.
It feels like falling it the music
of action. Yeah. Bumping, bumping,
tiptoeing. Yeah.
Bonking all of these things have a kind
of musical expression that feels almost
like a physical language that we came
into the world with and never had to
learn. And when I went to music school,
it was so difficult in dense because
suddenly I was thrust into this world of
contemporary classical composition and
it was all about understanding the rigor
of serial 12 tone composition,
which is like you create these little
mathematical systems that guide your
choices. And I was like, I don't
know what this has to do with music.
I don't understand this. And then
you hear it and you're like, I might,
you can't pick up on it. I feel lost.
You feel like you're
literally in the forest.
But then I encountered composers like
John Luther Adams where it wasn't about
that at all. Something more primal.
It was about like the movement of
bodies, you know, masses of sound,
that sort of crescendo decrescendo waves.
Yeah.
I do think of the sounds of musical
forms and events as forces as natural
elements in some way.
And it may sound ridiculously
grandiose or laughably naive,
but I've always imagined that I might
be able to work in a space that's just
outside of culture. Of
course, it's patently absurd.
There's no way that we work outside
of, of culture and these days,
so many cultures. And yet
as my friend Barry Lopez,
the Writers' says, landscape is the
culture that contains all human cultures.
And, uh,
I believe that everything we do,
everything we think,
everything we think we create,
anything we are derived from
the world that we inhabit,
our language, our music, our,
our minds, everything is,
is shaped by this incredibly complex
and wondrous world that we inhabit.
So ultimately this major culture or
dichotomy in a way doesn't exist,
but it's been a useful conceit for me to
feel that I'm after something that that
is not,
it's not part of a musical tradition.
It's not specifically cultural
that somehow more elemental
[inaudible].
Where does music come from?
How does a composer take an assignment
like write an 11 minute piece for string
quartet and translate those
instructions into a concept, into notes,
into a score for composer
John Luther Adams?
It seems almost like the
transformation happens in his sleep.
I try to resist composing
for as long as I can.
I really want to get
at something essential
before I start manipulating
notes, pushing things around.
I try to hold things in my mind's
ear as long as I can. It's a,
it's maybe an inefficient way to work,
but it has worked for me. I find
that if I'm trying to remember,
I'm trying to hear something
that I can't quite name.
It focuses my attention in a certain way
and then I finally start composing when
I can't not compose, when
I have to write it down.
I'm thinking about like the way that we
are discovering how memory and the brain
works and every time you
remember something you're
actually recreating a story.
Yes.
So I really like that you have an idea
and you are continually remembering it.
So basically you're making a lot of
mental xeroxes of it over and over again
until it becomes something which is so
steeped in your brain stuff than it is.
It is a piece. Exactly.
So night after night when
I lie down to go to sleep,
I'm imagining this group of instruments
in this particular space and what they
might sound like and how they might
move through the space physically and
through the musical space of, of
the piece. And it's repetitive.
I'm doing it every night. At a certain
point I lose it and I drift off to sleep.
That nocturnal composition process is
apparently what happened with John Luther
Adams. Most recent, most famous piece.
This is a piece I literally tried to
copy during our recent apocalyptical tour
and it just won the Pulitzer
Prize. Apparently John was, uh,
spending some time near the Pacific Ocean
and he would fall asleep to the sound
of ocean waves and it
seeped into his dream.
And what emerged when he finally started
to compose was this orchestral piece
for three orchestras actually
it's called become ocean.
And what happens in the pieces that
over the course of about 40 minutes,
all three orchestras form
these massive swells of sound.
With these three huge crescendos,
like massive tsunamis coming crashing
[inaudible] [inaudible]
I'm talking about the title of the piece
become ocean. John Luther Adams said,
life on this earth first
emerged from the sea.
As the polar ice melts
and sea levels rise,
we humans find ourselves facing the
prospect that once again we may quite
literally become ocean.
Um,
well here he is in a conversation
with WQXR is Helga Davis.
This is a global warming piece
and I would say everything that
I do these days is in some way,
um, addressing the, the state of
the world and the delicate and,
and precarious position of we're
human animals in the world. Um,
and yet I will also have the other
side of my mouth insist that it has
absolutely nothing to do with,
with current events or
politics or activism and that
music must stand on its own
as music. And um,
like I like to believe that
we can have it both ways.
It is very, very outdoors.
Yeah. And it's, it's without,
it seems like it hasn't had people in
it all as just openness. Yeah. Yeah.
You're floating on the surface
if you're there at all, eh,
[inaudible]
one of the many reasons you should
go to iTunes and download Q2 meet the
composer hour with John Luther Adams is
that they play this unreleased track of
his string quartet called the wind in
high places, which is just beautiful.
Go to radio lab.org.
We will link you to more information
about meet the composers.
I highly recommend this podcast.
Thank you so much to Nadia Sirota,
Alex Overton and Thea Challenor and Alex
Ambrose for allowing us to play some
excerpts. I'm Jad Abumrad. I remember
Covich. Thanks for listening.